I think one of the benefits of reading
fiction especially own voices fiction
own voices fiction is is stories about
experiences within minority communities
written by insiders write written by by
people who are part of those communities
I think own voices stories can be so
powerful because they really do give us
a glimpse of what it's like to inhabit
that life experience it gives us a
glimpse of what the world looks like
through those eyes with that marine
right and ultimately in my personal
reading experience it seems like leading
those stories ultimately it emphasizes
the common humanity that that we all
have I think I think that's sort of
that's sort of how your emphasis grows
in in our current world we are asked on
a regular basis to interact with people
who are very different from us own
voices stories are a great tool for us
to to figure out how to how to carry on
it carries through those interactions I
think and I also think that a great own
voices story will instill a certain
sense of humility in you because at the
end of that story you can have all these
questions in your brain you know and
you're going to realize those questions
are gonna make you realize how much you
don't understand about this other group
you know you just get a drop in the
bucket and in approaching people with
that humility I think is is so important
within a diverse world within a diverse
setting with cultural appropriation you
know the the first time I really thought
about this hard was actually with the
the last airbender movie it came out a
few years ago was based on this amazing
television show an animated TV series
called avatar last airbender which some
people say and I agree with this some
people say avatar last airbender is the
best written American animated series
ever so when they adapted this show from
the animated series to a live-action
film they took all of the
rolls this the original show was
actually set in the fantasy world but
it's a fantasy world that was based on
real world Asian cultures and if you
look at the show Bible if you look at
the show notes all the characters are
supposed to look either Asian or in wit
so they they took all those roles and
they gave them to white actors I was
really mad about it I ended up doing
this webcomic about how it's going to
boycott the movie through the day I've
never seen the movie but from what I've
heard the casting issues are the least
of the movies probably like Roger Ebert
said it was the worst movie of the
decade and when I read that I was like
man that dude watches a lot of movies
how bad is we have to be to be the worst
movie of the decade anyways that was
when I started really engaging I got in
touch with this group called race
bending calm which calls out you know
Hollywood in America via different
American storytelling industries on on
on casting issues on cultural
appropriation so cultural appropriation
I think I think it's a tricky issue
because it's difficult to say what is
being appropriated you know I think I
think a larger issue the larger question
might be this a larger question might be
when you are interacting with a culture
that is not your own when you are
interacting with culture that has no
roots no no ties to your family history
are you doing so in a humble and
respectful manner you know are you are
you going in with a certain sense of
humility and are you going in in a with
a posture of learning as opposed to a
posture of teaching or even worse
profiteering you know I think those are
those are the those are the big
questions within cultural appropriation
I know there's this there's this huge
debate about political quickness as well
and and whether or not it's exceeded its
original intention whether it's a good
thing or a bad thing or there it gets in
the way of having a sense of humor I can
hear all that right my understanding of
political correctness is this my
understanding is that political
correctness is all about people figuring
out what label
they themselves want to use it's giving
people power over their own identities
right like it's basically like me saying
I get to decide what you call me it's
tied into the history of colonialism the
history of keeping people feeling like
labels were placed on top of them and
they had no they had no say and and what
those labels were so I think that I
think the heart of political correctness
is is about our respect for human
dignity about a respect for the dignity
of every individual you know and then
that way
that way I think it's I think it's an
important just like I don't think we can
just get rid of political correctness I
don't think that that would be a good
thing do I do think that there is an
important conversation about the
interface the interface of of political
correctness and free speech I think
that's that that's an interesting part
and I don't have I don't feel like I
have any answers for that but I do think
that's an interesting and worthwhile
conversation to have in a respectful
manner
[Music]
you